[Music]
hello you just lost my friends
this is guns in here welcome to the 55th
episode of dirty jazz tricks in this
episode I'm going to show you a
wonderful attacking and a tricky line
against shilling gambit from the white
perspective the opening arises after the
following model evil ePHI and it doesn't
matter whether white continued with
Knight to f3 or Bishop to c4 let's say
in this game white played Bishop to c4
first and after Knight to c6 he
continued with Knight to f3 now the
typical shilling gambit arises on the
board after the move Knight to d4 which
is in fact at club level very effective
and black is playing for one car hoping
that white will take this pawn after
that Queen to g5 gives black or very
could came just within the opening stage
first let me quickly highlight what is
the problem in this position so as a
wide if you reach this position first
time you might be tempted to go ahead
with Knight captures f7 which in fact
hit the 2 piece but actually here the
fun begins for the black cam as after
Queen captures g2 attacking the rook
rook to a fun and now the winning move
Queen captures a fool
and no matter however white blocks he
has a completely losing position just
within 7 move of the game so no wonder
this sort of attack attract a lot of
beginners and if you check out YouTube
there are a lot of videos
exist in this line which no doubt
attract many people now the people who
know about this trap
they can easily refute this gambit
either with c3 d3 or castle and all this
moves gives wide a slight advantage
however personally I think middle game
theory is not that clear for the white
camp
so if black prepares well then obviously
he can get a very good game so that's
the reason why I have come up with this
video which not only gives you a very
attacking system against this line but
it also creates so many problems for the
black king and if your opponent doesn't
defend accurately then game can be
finished very quickly the funny part is
we are going to start with my captures
Aoife which black player will delighted
as he's going to spring out Queen to G
fire instantly and thinking that yet
another of my opponent fall into this
trap but the matter of fact is it is now
white who is going to surprise black
with the following sequence Bishop
captures Epsilon check King to e7 is
most popular choice however I have also
covered King to d8 in the PG in which in
fact not a good option either for the
black camp okay King to e7 black keep
pressurizing to pieces and don't forget
the g2 point is also hanging but here
comes the point behind playing this line
white is going to Castle at this point
sacrificing the whole piece now black is
forced to capture this piece as if he
continued to deny the piece with Knight
to f6
then we can simply consolidate this
night with the mu f fall and now the
naked King in the center gives white a
tremendous advantage in this position so
obviously black is not going to miss out
this and he's definitely going to grab
this piece thinking that white has made
an opening disaster but guess what here
is the moment where fun begins for the
white camp the forcing sequence goes as
follow Bishop captures g8 rook captures
g8 now c3 attacking the knight doesn't
matter wherever this Knight goes most
accurate choice is Knight to c6
after that yup you guessed it d4
attacking the Queen Queen to f6 and now
this pawn steamroller literally annoy
black all pcs with defy black has to
play Knight to e5 and after that yup
you cast it f4 another jab in the center
and after Knight to f7 and mu ePHI well
yep we have sacrificed our piece but see
yourself who is literally and joined the
game and toying with your opponent the
beauty about this variation is every
move is forced up to this point and as
black king is stuck in the center white
has an ample compensation with this
tremendous pawn chain at the center of
the ball and upcoming attack where for a
human black side it is almost
undefendable now to illustrate the
danger in this position I like to show
you a model game which will give you a
clear path how white should continue
from here onwards
we are following a game between two 2100
plus rated opponent where black continue
with Quinto at six getting out of the
attack and yep you can go head with the
moon fi but I like what white did in
this game namely night to d2 and that
night is heading towards the juicy
center efore square where even though
black knows about this he can't do
anything okay King to d8 happen
liberating the bishop Knight to e4 as
expected and now Bishop to d7 black is
trying to get his pieces out somehow in
order to achieve the equality well white
first done a console eating new King to
h1 and now in the view of FI black move
the Queen out with Queen to h4 but it
turns out that after White's next move
it is confirmed that white is having a
huge advantage from this position can
you guess the first killing move of the
game yes you are absolutely right if you
come up with this move d6 completely
shutting down black Queen side and after
pawn takes and pawn takes the horrible
scenario for the black camp occurs on
the board with Bishop to f6 and Queen to
defy attacking the weak babies in the
black camp it doesn't matter wherever
the black rook moves in the game choose
the move rook to e8 counter attacking
the white knight but what is not in a
rush
he simply developed the rest of the army
with Bishop to e3 and once the rook
joined into the attack it is the death
for the black cam Luke 2e6 happened
defending the night and now the last
Beast coming to the frame
Luke a to even and I think this sums up
very well that even though white is a
material down look at his Quinn side
completely jam up and virtually speaking
at this point white is in fact a piece
ahead well the game finished very
quickly from this position black
responded with King to eat only to face
this rude shock
Knight to c5 BAM the first important
point black cannot take on d6 the simple
reason is after Bishop to f2 we have a
disk of a chat to the King as well as
attack on the Queen and the resulting
sequence let's say Bishop to e7 Queen
captures g6 Knight captures d6 and now
Bishop captures h4 and funny enough it
is white who is come up with an exchange
up so practically speaking that rook
cannot move so in the game black decided
to play Knight to d8 defending the rook
but I think afterwards next reply black
sees that his position is a complete
goner
the third critical blow happen at this
point
yup it's Fi and white says well I'm
going to grab your rook for free as if
you try to give an exchange sac with
route captures it v white can deliver a
checkmate at the back rancor
so unfortunately that rook cannot move
and in the game black tried the move
Bishop to e5 which threatens a checkmate
but I don't think so a 2200 will miss
that h3 happen and after Queen to g3
white can simply bury all the threats
with Bishop to Jeevan and now indeed
threatening to of the black piece so
black finally decide that okay let me
just get rid of this very annoying d6
pawn but doing so he done the final
mistake of the game as white deliver
this finishing not maybe you can try it
just pause the video and find out a
sequence where white is completely
winning are you ready let's start F
captures c6 d captures c6 Knight
captures e6 and after Knight captures e6
here comes the final blue rook captures
e6 and the point is after Bishop takes
and Queen takes doesn't matter whatever
black plays he get a completely losing
position you can't block with the bishop
as you are going to lose a piece and if
you continue with King to d8 then
afterwards next accurate response rook
to f7 there is no way black and seem to
checkmate that's it
I hope you enjoy and learn this
wonderful attacking system against the
shilling gambit remember play the move
Knight captures 'if I allow view
opponent to play Queen to g5 and then
shock him with the following sequence
Bishop captures f7 King to e7 and now
Castle sacrificing the knight but
winning the game with a tremendous
attacking position thank you for
watching this video feel free to like
subscribe and comment and I will meet
you in my next episode very soon bye and
take care